Kelly Clarkson has just come
out and given marriage advice Kelly
Clarkson is recently divorced so not
great to get marriage advice probably
from a recent
divor she
says three things here that are totally
wrong one she says love is not forever
love is never forever you know you got
to remember that going in two you really
want to make sure you're in a position
where you don't need anything from your
partner okay you don't want to be
dependent on them and three you just got
to go to therapy all the time therapy is
really really
great all three of those things are
totally
wrong I've always known that love is
hard for me love has always come with
this elephant in the room of sadness
I've known love is not forever I don't
mean that to sound depressing but I
think we put a lot of pressure on that
word sometimes love is looking at
someone and going this is not for you
this is not good for
me that's a hard thing to face but when
you do I think you grow yes you grow
very
sad but you don't you don't grow in that
you don't you're not edified by that
you're not Sanctified by that you're
usually you're you just left right back
at square one and then you started again
but she said she said love is so sad to
me because I know it's never going to
actually go anywhere we'll see how far
along it gets but then eventually one of
us is going to pull the pl plug that is
not the way to look at it that is the
way of looking at love as a matter of
emotion and Caprice and individual
preference that is not how our society
has traditionally viewed love that's not
how love actually works love is willing
the good of the other person for that
person's own sake love is an action that
we performed love is something that we
are commanded to do as Christians if you
were a Christian uh but I think we're
all commanded to do it actually by the
god of the Universe
um you have to do it even when you don't
want to you have to do it even when you
just look at someone and you go this is
not good for you this is not good for me
yeah let's let just quit no you still
have to do it when you make a commitment
to somebody you just have to follow it
out and and not only do you have to
follow it out in this this tedious way
where it's just drudgery and and and
difficult all day long you need to
figure out how to make it work and
Thrive and if something's not working
right then you need to to recognize that
love is an objective thing outside of
your own emotions and you need to do it
and if you are not perfectly willing the
good of the other person for that
person's own sake and vice versa then
work it out figure out but otherwise
you'll just be left with what she admits
is just a a big elephant in the room of
sadness if it's all just a negotiation
and a Gamble and and based on individual
Choice rather than objective reality
between the social animals between human
beings then it's always going to flop
second one dating sucks it's so awkward
I was single until I was like 30 and I
forgot how really good at that I am I
told a friend that a potential partner
would have to be an individual that
brings their own life to the table with
without needing anything from me it's
far more romantic to say I want you but
I don't need anything what I'm really
good right now I'm having a good time
what are you talking about this is total
Millennial cope I don't mean to be too
harsh on Kelly Clarks in here but it's a
teachable moment and she's saying things
that are just completely insane I think
part of the reason that Millennials in
particular are having trouble getting
married is that people sometimes we
harden a little bit we aify a little bit
okay when you're young you know you're
really malleable you try on different
personalities you try out different
ideas you you're you're a sponge you you
learn new words and behaviors it's
easier to learn a foreign language for
example as you get older you kind of
aify a little bit and Harden so if
you're a little if you're a little clump
of putty you're 15 years old you're a
little clump of putty you got your
15-year-old girlfriend she's a little
clump of putty and you're all just a
little putty and you get smooshed
together and then you start to harden
over you're going to harden into shape
with one another if you're your Reg
clumps of putty and you're totally
separate an individual and you just
remain totally
alone you're going to harden into your
own shapes it's going to be a lot harder
to smash you two together okay there's
going to be little gaps there's going to
be little air pockets it's got little
parts are going to break off it's going
to be difficult I'm not saying it can't
happen I know plenty of friends who've
gotten married not just in their 30s
which is now the norm but 40s
50s it can happen it's a it's a fallen
world and we do what we can but it's
going to be a lot easier you don't want
someone who is totally fully formed with
all of their own tastes preferences
beliefs behaviors every and then you
have exactly the
same when it comes to your tastes
preferences behaviors whatever and
you're just going to mash them up in a
kind of a negotiated partnership you
want to grow together is what you want
you want you your wife to be a part of
your flesh okay another another part of
you you're going to develop those things
together not you you want want
dependence you want to share a bank
account you want
to be together a lot you want to do that
otherwise it's going to be like an
you're running an accounting firm and
you've got to have board meetings every
week to decide basic questions third one
she goes I'm taking my power back that
sounds very therapy but that's because I
love therapy and I think it's important
to have these those tools to navigate
your life in
relationships how many people that you
know who who are constantly in therapy
are
happy not very many probably now you
might say well yeah that's why they're
in therapy okay how many people who are
in therapy for a really long time seem
to get
better very few I'm not saying it can't
happen it does happen Drew claven he
says he's the one guy ever in history
who got cured by a therapist and then he
stopped going to the therapist because
he got better I know people who go to
therapists for years decades they only
ever seem to get worse in some cases
they just use the therapist as a drug
dealer you know a psychiatrist okay get
me more depression pills or something
but in in some cases it it's a better
form of therapy which is cognitive
behavioral therapy or some kind of talk
therapy working through problems but
even then a therapist is only as good as
the premises he he brings to it right if
a therapist starts with the premise that
there is no God there is no soul you're
just a bag of chemicals the only purpose
in life is to to amass pleasure and
we're going to look at the through the
the Viewpoint of hedonistic
utilitarianism okay you know I don't
think that's conducive to human
flourishing if your therapist comes in
and is a Christian and recognizes that
you do have a soul and that life is
about more than just feeling pleasure
and doesn't believe that marriage is
dissoluble and doesn't believe all this
nonsense that Kelly Clarkson's been
saying then you're probably going to
have a better
therapist but which is it we just
because we live in such a uh decadent
and uh philosophically and theologically
shallow Society it's not that we got rid
of our priests it's just that we anoint
new people to be our priests you can
never get rid of the priests there is a
Priestly class in every society ever
throughout all of human history every
little no no two-bit tribe in papaa New
Guinea has some kind of a priest class
that's something that human life demands
we deny it we say we killed all priests
we all the the society will only
flourish when we strangle the last king
with the entrails of the last priest you
know all this kind of craziness that
came out of the Enlightenment and the
French Revolution and but it's not true
there's always going to be priests
there's this human need and this this
exercise of power is always going to be
there it's just going to move around and
we
have anointed therapists with a lot of
that Prestige from the Priestly class
but what if they're totally wrong what
what if they're not up to the job what
if even they they're very well-
intentioned but they don't have really
solid thoughts on theology ontology
anthropology what happens then you get a
ton of Confusion And you get a bunch of
Feelgood you know slogans that you could
buy on one of those signs they sell at
TJ Max you know and the and the the
highest moral theological Maxim that you
ever hear is live laugh love live laugh
love is fine to spruce up you know a
powder room it's not fine to live your
life by it it doesn't it doesn't
interpret itself and it can lead you
down this path of yeah just do whatever
feels good in the moment thank you
therapist see you next time really
really bad advice Kelly Clarkson I have
a soft spot for her but that's terrible
advice that was a great clip now you got
to ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls YouTube channel we'll see
you next time